you were homeschooled yes and for all of
your education yeah for yes for most of
my education you have two kids I don't
care if it thought about homeschooling
your kids but I would say stop it
it's the awful idea yeah don't so I was
home-schooled and just for religious
reasons my mom is very religious and
actually didn't allow us to watch any TV
growing up so no school no TV and that
was a problem because I was actually
this is like huge for me to be here
because I was a huge fan of your show
from a very young age but you weren't
allowed to watch it weren't allowed to
watch it so I found a workaround and my
plan to continue to watch your show
because my mom saw and she was like no
man should move like that should string
really just sect has embraced me yet
yeah unclaimed blamed yeah so my plan
and this is completely true to work
around this to continue to watch your
guys's show was to convince my mom to
sign me up for this homeschool program
called Christian video Academy mm-hmm
and what Christian video Academy does is
they will film their classrooms like
real classrooms with the teachers and
students in them you've seen movies and
then they will send those tapes to
different homeschool students throughout
the country so you can like work along
with those students and the sole purpose
of signing up for this program was so I
could get my own TV and VCR in my room
to secretly record your show at Wow so
you would wait so you would use the
tapes that they sent you right the these
Christian tapes yes you would use those
tapes and you would tape over them
actual school I would tape I would leave
10 minutes of the real class at the
front of the tape and then I would press
record it'd be like hey folks that was
our musical guest Bush and then that's
and then you would come on I was
supposed to be Jay Leno was the worst
right now supposed to be me for a second
and I was really and so no usually my
spot-on yeah okay yeah so then so then
so let me just record over these videos
and I was very slick about it I don't
only do it at night I turn the TV off so
it's definitely not helping with ratings
and and and I never got caught but what
I failed to realize is that every month
not only do they not watch the dough are
you every month you have to send the
tapes back to Christian video Academy
right yes and Christian video Academy
does not watch the tapes back for
quality control
they just blindly send them to other
homeschool students which means like
some homeschool student be sitting
through like a Christian science class
where they're like you know
photosynthesis is caused by the devil
that video cuts out and then on comes
like the FedEx Pope or the masturbating
bear masturbating bear whatever terrible
no pain user who did you you brought you
you had an example and this is real so
enough students had complained about me
recording over these videos that
Christian video Academy actually
launches an internal investigation they
trace the tapes back to our address they
sent my mom a very angry letter in all
caps that says like you've damaged our
curriculum it's been recorded over by a
program that is quote not in line with
our core Christian values and along with
the letter they said my mom an example
tape back and yes I brought kept it a
clip this is this is absolutely real
yeah one this is like the first time
anyone's ever brought actual school as a
clip yeah on your show but this is from
mrs. Robinson's science class and before
it cuts out you'll see a little bit of
her class and well one thing that was
interesting about mrs. Robinson is she
would do like pretty mundane hands-on
science experiments right but she would
treat them all like she had just done
witchcraft for us like she would heat up
water and be like and that's how vapors
made
right so we'll see a little bit of her
class before it cuts out a program that
is not in line let's take a look at this
tape that got you in a lot of trouble
let's take a look here we go one two
three and in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now I was like completely busted
they sent the worst example it was
almost cued up like it like a sitcom
would so now it's completely busted with
the school but I was able to intercept
the letter and the tape before my mom
saw it so now my new plan I was just
about to give up on recording you guys a
show but then I realized that Christian
video Academy I just made a crucial
mistake by sending me a video back to
essentially snitch on me all they had
done was just giving me an extra tape so
now we could just keep recording on that
one tape and over and over and over yeah
and then not touch the new school don't
ever touch me like being sent but the
only problem now is that like when I
wanted to watch a show back I would have
to like hover over the TV ready to like
switch out the tapes at any moment rice
by mom came in they just doing school as
I always do just a high yeah yeah all
sweaty and hunched over like never got
caught though yeah right two years ago I
started sort of working for your show I
was so excited about it and still
excited about it
and I told my older brothers this I was
like isn't this cool I'm working for his
show now cuz I don't if you guys know
this but I would actually be secretly
recording his show in my room at night
and my older brother Jonah goes oh
that's what you were doing in there ya
know we always fully heard you
frantically shuffling around with
different VHS tapes in your room we just
thought that you were furiously
masturbating to different VHS tapes
do you know how insane and gross that no
I do I do
yeah it's a lot it's like one thing to
have like multiple porn tabs open during
a session it's a whole nother thing to
feel like have the sexual appetite you
know you need to switch out different ya
ya chest tapes kids today don't know how
lucky they are they don't know I'm 77
and also this is like 2005 in 2004 so
this is like internet porn is readily
available but not only am i accrete
jerkin it's different clips but I'm also
like a vinyl snob about
where I'm like no thank you pornhub
streaming I much prefer the textures the
VHS